never before has the nation been so
caught up in watching a delivery packed
up
shipped out and flown to its
destinations
all under the watchful eyes of security
usually anonymous workers
now i'm very humble and
and happy to to
let the healing begin these are the
first coronavirus vaccines from pfizer
almost 3 million doses shipped out
across the country and it led to very
unusual
live television it's not often you hear
this when anyone gets a shot
three two one
vaccinate yeah state governors from
kentucky to colorado new york to
louisiana waiting to see them arrive
with this shipment we start to see our
ability to preserve life and protect our
people
we are going to defeat covet and it
starts right there
one of the first shots watched on live
television an intensive care nurse in
new york who wanted to send a message
i hope this march will begin into the
end of a very
painful time in our history
i want to instill public confidence
that the vaccine is safe all of these
made for tv moments meant to let people
know that the vaccine
is safe and everyone should take it when
they can
as polls show as many as 50 of adults
say they won't
there's also a question about how long
it will take to have enough vaccine for
all americans
so right now we said 50 million for this
year and most of them already has been
manufactured and we are allocating it
and
next year will be 1.3 billion and we are
working
to make much more than that so the 1.3
billions it is our commitment to the
world
but we are working to make much more
another vaccine from the company moderna
is expected to get approval
later this week that will increase
supply and experts say they think
that that means by the spring every
american who wants to get the
vaccination
will be able to find one it's positive
news but it comes
a very grim day as it's announced that
the u.s has now lost 300
000 people because of kovid and experts
say
without big changes it's only going to
continue to get worse
patti culhane al jazeera washington